bfm politique avec télé chevrillon le
rendement n'est notre invité et françois
bayrou monsieur bayrou nous connaissons
la composition du premier gouvernement
du nouveau quinquennat d'emmanuel
vaincrons un gouvernement qui est déjà
touchée par une affaire avec des
révélations faites par mediapart nos
confrères ont recueilli les témoignages
de deux femmes qui accusent damien abad
nouveau ministre venu des républicains
de viol des faits je le précise qu'il
conteste fermement et affirme qu'il ya
toujours eu un consentement mutuel
des factures également été porté à la
connaissance des partis politiques
auxquels ils ont mis la partie tenues ou
appartient encore comment vous réagissez
je ne sais rien de cette affaire je n'ai
aucun élément pour
même pour y réfléchir il ya une justice
il ya un
déroulé des enquêtes je n'ai aucune
opinion sur ce sujet je vois très bien
les temps que nous vivons dans les temps
que nous vivons les personnalités
responsables sont tellement souvent
ciblés mais je n'ai pas de problème à
des volumes interrogé alors qu'il entre
au gouvernement
ce n'est pas moi qui ai formé le
gouvernement je n'avais aucune
information sur ce sujet ni avant ni
après ni de près ni de loin je ne sais
pas s'il est je peux pas répondre autre
chose et je voudrais qu'on réfléchisse
tous ceux qui commentent
s'ils ont des éléments c'est normal
qu'ils commentent s'ils n'ont pas
d'éléments mais dans une dans un
déséquilibre
juste une chose une question on a du mal
à comprendre depuis la sphère cahuzac
tout ce qui entre dans un gouvernement
sont passés au crible au tamis on
regarde tout la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique on
regarde leurs impôts leur patrimoine
leur casier judiciaire on leur fait même
signé une charte de moralité on pouvait
pas prévoir ça avant
on dit toujours qu'on contrôle on dit
toujours qu'on passe au crible on dit
toujours que c'est des vérifications
comme il n'y en a jamais eu et en
réalité vous voyez et c'est pas la
première fois et c'est depuis très
longtemps que vérification ne valent que
ce que valent les informations des
vérificateurs et donc gg pas souvent
accorder beaucoup de crédit à ces
vérifications
sachant ce que je dit on quand je dis ça
je pense à des faits précis et françois
bayrou est ce que dans quelles
conditions doit qu'il restait au
gouvernement d'accord est-ce qu'il faut
attendre que la justice tranche vous
voyez
et journalise votre immense mais via
trois heures de temps
nous ignorions et vous et moi et laurent
nomades et jean baptiste boursier nous
ignorions absolument de damien abad
avait reçu des accusations
et nous n'avons aucun élément aucune
preuve aucune indication aucune
nous n'avons aucun élément et vous en
êtes déjà à dire est-ce qu'il peut
rester au gouvernement vous voyez cette
surenchère et c'est cet engrenage s'il y
a des éléments il y aura des enquêtes
s'il ya des enquêtes il y aura des
décisions de justice ou autre et donc ou
moins en tout cas je ne je n'entre pas
dans cette surenchère que ça soit fondée
ou pas si c'est fondé normal que il y
ait des suites si ça n'est pas fondée
c'est très problématique de d'alimenter
ce genre de chose mais encore une fois
je ne dis ça ni pour ni contre mais en
faveur ni en défaveur monsieur bayrou
est ce qu'un problème dans la classe
politique française est ce que la classe
politique française n'a pas nommé pas
trop de temps à
dénoncer changer ses comportements être
plus moral non
d'abord un jeu contest qui est une
classe politique cette idée de classe
politique ça suppose que c'est des gens
qui se protègent les uns les autres si
je devais avoir un diagnostic c'est
parce c'est pas qui se protège c'est
qu'ils sont très contents des
accusations qui circulent des uns contre
les autres des narces politique car il
n'y a pas de moeurs politiques ya des
hommes et des femmes qui sont désormais
dans des situations où les projecteurs
sont braqués sur eux et si on faisait
une enquête sur chacun de ceux qui sont
autour de la table probablement
découvrir et on que ya peut-être des
zones grises tous parce que je ne
connais aucun être humain qui soit d'une
transparence absolue mais entrer dans
des perpétuelles mise en accusation
dénonciation qui entraîne évidemment là
la sortie ou en tout cas l'exclusion de
ceux qui sont aux responsabilités alors
je trouve que c'est excessif et qu'on ne
sait pas garder le les principes les
principes c'est que s'il ya des
accusations il ya des enquêtes s'il ya
des enquêtes il ya des décisions de
justice et c'est les décisions de
justice qui font foi comme ça que je le
vis c'est comme ça que vous l'avez vécu
vous à titre personnel quand vous avez
dû tuer le gouvernement est un peu un
peu pire encore parce que j'ai des jets
privés la maison j'étais nombre on va
surveiller merci
non nous avons été accusé de quelque
chose dont je considère un que ce n'a
rien d'immoral et deuxièmement que nous
nous étions totalement certain de ne pas
avoir commis ce genre de choses et ça
sera prouvé il ya déjà des décisions de
justice dont personne n'a été averti un
des assistants des eurodéputés et ses
rangs en accuse quatre partis politiques
au moins c'est à dire le front national
mélenchon nous est
maintenant
candidat du parti communiste à
l'élection présidentielle fabien roussel
d'avoir travaillé pour leur parti en
tant qu assistant parlementaire 1 je
considère que ce n'est pas immoral mais
vraiment pas parce que je peux faire une
liste de centaines d'assistants
parlementaires vous prenez prenez tout
ce qui se sont engagés dans leur partie
puisque les parlementaires sont désignés
par les partis mais nous ne l'avons pas
fait nous te d'alors on a été ciblé j'ai
donc vécu ça comme une absolue injustice
je m'en serais moquer s'il n'y avait pas
eu des conséquences
humaines tragiques monsieur bayrou pour
pour claire sur ce sujet pour l'instant
de damien abad vous évoquez tout à
l'heure de possibles zones grises pour
chacun d'entre nous mais en tous cas me
concernant je le souhaite également pour
vous elle ne concerne pas des
accusations de viol
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est quand même très particulier et
particulière bien je le dis que j'en
utilise acquisitions menées l'enquète
vous
ne me demandez pas de modèle enquête moi
non je ne mens pas non mais si vous avez
joué éléments vous demande votre
réaction en tant que responsable
politique important qui est dans ceux en
ce moment de plus de nombreuses années
c'est en tant que responsable politique
je ne sais pas si c'est important ou pas
mais je peux vous dire que j'ai vu me
l'accusation
dont certaines étaient fondées et
d'autres étaient infondées et que donc
l'attitude
légitime
républicaine puisque vous employer le
mot c'est de faire la différence entre
les accusations
les enquêtes et les décisions de justice
et encore une fois je ne sais absolument
rien de cette affaire non mais
franchement pas plus que vous et pas
plus que j'imagine à moins que vous ayez
des éléments mais une question il fut un
temps que nous avons connus où il
fallait attendre une décision de justice
pour quelqu'un ne puisse plus siéger
dans un gouvernement puis on est passé à
la mise en examen la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est nous nous avons
choisi de l'air avant la mise en examen
est ce que la seule accusation lorsqu'on
est sur des faits aussi graves jean
baptiste le disait qu'un violent une
agression sexuelle est ce que la seule
accusation doit suffire à empêcher
quelqu'un de rentrer dans un
gouvernement c'est ça la question et la
question corollaire par des mois je
parle oui car
c'est la prise en compte de la parole
des victimes ce qui est une bataille
fondamentale
ces questions sont tranchés par la
décision du président de la république
et du premier ministre c'est eux on la
responsabilité de la composition de leur
équipe
points
alors cette une première ministre
elisabeth bornes elle tient donc son
premier gouvernement dont l'annoncé a
pris beaucoup de temps beaucoup de temps
entre la réélection des manuels macron
la nomination de madame borné et la
composition de son gouvernement est ce
que sa composition vous surprend ou
est-ce que vous la trouvez efficace vous
dire quelque chose qui n'a pas été dit
du tout pendant cette période
ce gouvernement
est celui qui va devoir faire face
si je ne me trompe pas au pire crise que
la france ait connu depuis la guerre
crise plus grave pour moi la guerre
d'algérie je sais que ça a été les
consciences la guerre d'algérie chose
extrêmement
pourquoi
c'est mon diagnostic
c'est ma vision est gelée exprimé
pendant toute cette période
1 nous sommes un pays fracturée et
fracturée au pire endroit au plus
mauvais endroit
qu'on puisse imaginer pour une fracture
si la france était un bateau c'est sa
charpente qui serait fracturé est
pourquoi parce que il y à une rupture
méchante
entre la base de la société française et
son prétendu sommet ceux qui sont aux
responsabilités au pouvoir de
l'administration et du pouvoir politique
les les français de
de la base du pays dont ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui n'ont pas des
salaires mirobolants ceux qui n'ont ni
fortune ni pouvoir ni influence se
ressentent comme non seulement abandonné
mais extérieur aux décisions au
raisonnement de ceux qui sont
aux responsables et nous venons
d'ailleurs dans les questions de pouvoir
d'achat mais ce que du coup cette équipe
est elle est composée de faire penser
que vous décrivez laissez-moi aller
jusqu'au bout et c'est chris est un pays
frère à l'est et les crises qui viennent
on n'est pas au bout de la crise de
l'ukraine de très loin il va avoir des
aspects agricoles alimentaires pour le
monde entier
songez ce que la pénurie de blé dur peut
faire en afrique l'afrique du nord et en
afrique subsaharienne songer à sa via
l'ukraine avec la possibilité d'un
dérapage militaire d'un dérapage
un accident gravissime
kiné qui n'est pas écartée deuxièmement
il ya ce qui se passe en chine personne
en parle personne ne le voit mais il ya
des centaines peut-être plus d'un
millier de porte conteneurs
qui sont bloqués
au port de shanghai ne pouvant ni entrer
ni sortir en raison du zéro que vides et
du bouclage total un thalweg bloc après
il faut mais vous voyez que ça touche
les chaînes d'approvisionnement et
demandé aux industriels français et on
retient au btp les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
sont bloqués troisièmement je suis
jamais rassuré sur ce qui se passe au pr
au proche et moyen orient
si vous si vous envisagez ces crises là
avec les conséquences économiques
qu'elles vont avoir sur une société
fracturée vous ne pouvez pas ne pas voir
qu'il ya quelque chose de il ya des
nuages noirs à l'horizon et moi je
regarde le gouvernement avec 7 et à la
avec ce prisme là cette responsabilité
là et je sais que le choix que le
président de la république a fait est
que la première ministre a en tête c'est
d'avoir à affronter ça en changeant la
manière en tout cas c'est leur volonté
la manière d'exercer le pouvoir au
passage c'est plus vite dit que fait m
alors la question c'est ce que ce
gouvernement vous paraît batailler pour
affronter ces clichés salle hergé les et
je le soutiendrai en ce sens et deuxième
question mais qui concerne plus votre
formation politique
monsieur fesneau a hérité de
l'agriculture c'est un membre de votre
formation politique le modem l'abbé n'a
hérité du ministère de la mer d'ailleurs
un secrétariat d'état les professionnels
de la mer regrette que ce soit pas un
ministère deux ministres pour le modem
c'est suffisant non on n'avait pas
l'impression d'avoir été un peu
maltraité si vous si vous me posez une
question sentimentale que non sens
éthique ce que deux bien sûr nous
pouvions déçu voilà non je veux pas
je ne veux pas prendre les problèmes par
le petit bout de la lorgnette si dans la
situation où nous sommes
nous croyons que c'est au travers de
notre propre intérêt de notre de notre
engagement de familiale si j'ose dire
qu'il faut examiner les choses alors moi
je ne veux pas le voir ainsi je trouve
vraiment que que
notre rapport aurait pu être plus
important j'espère qu'il le sera dans la
deuxième vague après lille le serein
lorsqu'il y aura des gouvernements
justement pensez-vous est ce que vous
considérez vous avez été un peu victime
de l'ouverture à gauche de l'ouverture à
droite on va y revenir est-ce que vous
avez l'assurance dans cette deuxième
vague de nominations qui devraient avoir
lieu en juin parait-il après les
élections législatives
ce que j'ai reçu l'assurance qu'il y
aura plus de ministres ou ministres de
léguer voire de segré tan est un modem
je vais vous dire quelque chose de dans
les formations de gouvernement il n'ya
jamais d'assurance ceux qui croient aux
promesses qu'on leur fait ont très
souvent été déçu dans la vie politique
française donc que je je ne me fonde pas
sur des assurances mais voilà je ne me
fonde sur aucune demande nous ne
quémandons pas je ne me fonde sur aucun
chantage ne faisons pas de chantage je
me fonde sur ce que je sais que cette
formation politique apporte à la vie
politique disons que
le trouverez heureux que c'est cet
apport sera étoffe schwab soit plus
utile monsieur bayrou la principale
surprise du gouvernement
des élèves et bornes en l'état c'est la
nomination de pap ndiaye le ministre de
l'éducation de la jeunesse il succède à
jean michel blanquer évidemment vous
avez lu vous avez vu les attaques de
l'extrême droite qui le visent il serait
indigéniste islamo gauchiste il voudrait
effacer l'histoire de france car regard
vous portez sur cette entrée en
politique je disais hier il a un peu le
temps de goûter l'eau a dit rien était
ce direct dans le grand bain alors je ne
je ne crois en rien à ces accusations je
vais essayer de vous expliquer pour je
dois dire la vérité je ne connaissais
pas monsieur njawe connaissez sa soeur
et la grande romancière marie
que j'apprécie beaucoup mais je ne le
connaissais pas lu et je n'avais pas
suivi les polémiques précédente donc
vous vous êtes repus dans le cul non non
vous êtes
dans lesquels veut dont vous avez rendu
compte voilà voilà
sur sa domination au musée
de l'immigration et donc je ne le
connaissais pas et donc regarder son
oeuvre
j'ai regardé son parcours et j'ai
regardé ce qu'il a dit je veux dire une
chose avec certitude c'est un parcours
qui honore
l'avocat ducation nationale
voilà
un jeune garçon qui est fils de une
institutrice
française et d'un responsable sénégalais
le premier
africain en tout cas sénégalais à être
entré à l'école des ponts et chaussées
et qui a fait sa carrière dans des
responsabilités au sénégal il est le
fils de ces deux histoires de l'histoire
qui a réuni ces deux cet homme et cette
femme
et il a fait un parcours universitaire
qui est
en tout cas a salué donc vous malgré
chevron vous n'avez rien vu de
polémiques dans cinq ans de jurado je
viens à cette histoire bon après il a
fait des travaux
sur les états unis et notamment sur les
minorités aux états unis si rendu l'air
s'il ya vécu je crois si il y à un sujet
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour ceux qu'on
appelle les sociologues ceux qui
étudient les sociétés s'il ya un sujet
qui est marquant qui aveugle qui crève
les yeux c'est ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis à propos des minorités vous
voyez revenir aux états unis de manière
semble-t-il irrésistible et train pas
joué un rôle dans tout ça et
et les différents
mort de deux jeunes ou 2 ou 2 août eu
deux personnes sur lesquelles la police
a tiré et la couleur de la peau joue un
rôle très simple s'il ya un sujet
international dans le monde des sociétés
auxquelles on doit
réfléchir et flexion et u2 c'est ce
sujet là ou alors je me trompe bon
et dont cette affaire-là il ya deux
considérations la première
l'éducation nationale ces valeurs sont
universelles
on ne regarde pas la couleur de la peau
on ne regarde pas l'origine on ne
regarde pas la religion on n'a qu'un
seul but c'est l'émancipation
le que chacun se forge son esprit
critique c'est-à-dire sa capacité de
juger pour être libre c'est ça
deuxièmement ces valeurs universelles
elles sont le ciment de la société
française et il faut les transmettre
troisièmement bien entendu il faut
regarder ceux qui ont une histoire
différente et il faut les comprendre
parce qu'autrement vous ne jouez pas le
rôle que l'école doit jouer c'est à dire
de creuser république à monsieur byron
poursuivre nos échanges dans un instant
pour la suite de fn politique
la suite de bfm politique en compagnie
de françois bayrou vous êtes aussi
ancien ministre de l'éducation nationale
du coup nous en profitons vous
interroger sur la nomination laurent de
pap ndiaye oui on a beaucoup focalisé
sur l'opposition réelle ou supposée
entre jean michel blanquer à pap ndiaye
mais pardon l'important pour toutes
celles et tous ceux qui nous regardent
c'est qu'est ce que l'on doit faire pour
l'éducation nationale et j'imagine que
le nouveau ministre est là pour
appliquer la feuille de route du
président de la république
revalorisation du métier d'enseignant
réforme du lycée professionnel le retour
des maths ou pas l'autonomie des
établissements c'est quand même ça qu'on
attend d'abord d'un ministre de
l'éducation alors vous avez totalement
raison sur un point
c'est que un ministre de l'éducation
veut vite sa feuille de route est fixé
par le président de la république a jeté
sa feuille de route est fixé par l'état
de l'école par les problèmes par les
difficultés
par la crise incroyable que l'école vie
et cette crise demandé à tous les
enseignants sur les copies qui corrige
c'est une crise qui les amène parfois à
désespérer les problèmes
de niveau
qui sont ceux de l'école en france pas
seulement mesuré dans les enquêtes
internationales
ce qu' il y aurait sûrement beaucoup pas
amélioré ou beaucoup à dire sur les
enquêtes internationales mais mesurée
dans chaque famille dans chaque classe
g comme vous savez des enfants
enseignants nombreux et enseignant à
l'entrée à l'université le le
le désarroi
de ceux que dans bien des cas l'école
n'arrive plus à transmettre et qui fait
le socle de notre de notre vie en commun
le fait que des enseignants ont beaucoup
de mal à faire cours
la crise des vocations qu'on est en
train de vivre il n'y a plus de deux
vocations ou très peu elles sont de
qualité j'espère mais il n'ya plus de
vocations tout cela c'est ça la feuille
de route du nouveau ministre alors il
faut changer beaucoup de choses je vais
vous dire une chose qui pour moi est
nécessaire il faut rendre de la
lisibilité à l'école le les parents ont
tellement de mal à comprendre les
cheminements
si mystérieux si complexes qui se sont
qui ont été au travers du temps qui se
sont multipliés il faut rendre de la
lisibilité il faut que les parents quel
que soit leur niveau social leur leur
profession leur origine leur culture
faut que les parents comprennent ce qui
se passe à l'école et qu'ils le
soutiennent ajustements france à la
différence eu une phrase encore alors la
différence entre
les enfants qui réussissent à l'école et
ceux qui ne réussissent pas c'est pas
souvent l'une s'est pas seulement le
niveau mettons culturelle des familles
c'est les familles qui soutiennent
l'école qu'il aime pour qui c'est
important et celle pour qui c'est
secondaire
si c'est secondaire l'échec est promis
cissé soutenu si les familles
soutiennent alors exactement comme la
famille n'diaye vous voyez les les deux
enfants vous savez que c'était une
famille la maman est était enseignante
vous voyez que c'est une famille pour
qui l'école était un peu comme en france
aveyron vous connaissez très bien et
pour cause de l'éducation nationale est
ce que ça vous paraît le bon choix pour
réformer parce que vous même vous dit
regardez l'état de l'école est ce que
c'est le bon choix le bon profil pour
réformer l'éducation nationale je veux
dire pour reprendre un mot polémique
pour réformer le mammouth en tout cas
c'est le profil de quelqu'un qui a du
poids personnel et qui sera ou devrait
être respecté en tant que tel mais avec
le parcours que je signale ouais ya
forcément quelqu'un de républicains
c'est forcément quelqu'un d'
universaliste ça n'est pas ce qu'on
l'accuse d alors justement de ne pas
subir aussi à monsieur bayrou sauf que
emmanuel macron est évidemment une
connaissance beaucoup trop fine de ceux
de la politique et son exercice pour ne
pas savoir qu'il serait visé par les
critiques
derrière chaque chose il souvent un
petit peu de tactique est ce que le
président de la république selon vous à
utiliser sept nominations en plus des
qualités évidentes de cet homme et que
vous décrivez comme une forme de
diversion politique non vis-à-vis de la
gauche non c'est complètement stupide
non il s'est préoccupé avec l'agent
styles témoin avec beaucoup de
conscience
de trouver quelqu'un qui pourrait en
effet
résoudre cette structure qui était en
train de se créer à l'école entre ceux
qui ne voulait s'occuper que des
minorités ce qui ne voulait s'occuper
que des fondamentaux universaliste et il
faut nécessairement quelqu'un qui soit
capable de porter les deux messages
c'est un message 2 le message de je veux
pas que vous disputez n'a jamais le le
message de ce que cole retrouve par les
fondamentaux qu'elle transmet
l'uni recèle aucun
bien sur l'égalité des chances mais
c'est pas
ça n'est pas l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'est que chacun se forge une capacité
bien sûr de vivre et d'être et de au
sujet du g2 la vie au sujet des choix de
personnes laurent dans cette nouvelle
équipe gouvernementale
oui moi j'ai une question et j'avoue que
je me la pose depuis avant même la
formation du gouvernement mais dès la
désignation d'elisabeth board j'ai du
mal à comprendre comment le président de
la république a pu hésiter aussi
longtemps nous dit on jusqu'au dernier
moment même nous dit on entre deux
profils aussi différents que elisabeth
bornes finalement nommé et catherine
vautrin pour a priori mener la même
politique celle définie par le président
de la république est développée pendant
la campagne présidentielle comme on peut
hésiter entre deux profils aussi
différents
en tout cas moi je ne je n'ai pas été
informé de cette hésitation
à vous ne savent ou non et donc si
évidemment vous avez informé vous savez
je vous en avais même discuté du 9e oui
on lui dira le on le raconte mais vous
ne le connaissez trail ce que les
journaux écrivent vous savez je me méfie
beaucoup
non je pense que
pour moi il n'y avait pas lieu d'hésiter
citation il y a eu pour moi il n'y avait
pas lieu d'hésiter le les abeilles borne
à une expérience et surtout une
[Musique]
aile et dans dans le mouvement de pensée
du président de la république elle n'est
pas extérieure elle a mené toutes les
campagnes avec nous elle a été au
gouvernement pendant cinq ans il y
aurait eu une forme de
étrangeté à voir que que que ce n'est
pas dans le courant principal je pense
que ils étaient treize ans il est très
important qu'il y ait
une complicité et une complicité et une
entente entre le président de la
république et son premier ministre vous
êtes chez d'ailleurs vous nous confirmez
d'ailleurs qu'à titre personnel vous
avez peser pour que ce soit l autre a eu
confirmation donc tourner ou là oui
c'est ça au départ la jeune firme rien
ce que vous décrivez les cheveux bayrou
vous décrivez potentiellement françois
bayrou est-il vrai que vous aviez envie
de ce poste est vrai que vous aviez
envie d'être un lâche je ne pouvais pas
être dans cet état d'esprit parce que je
savais depuis des mois que le président
de la république voulait nommer une
femme
or je ne correspond pas au stéréotype
jeunesse est un critère plus important
que la non je pense qu'il avait décidé
de nommer une femme et je comprends très
bien pourquoi il l'a fait et je ne veux
et je pense que que
donc l'idée que
encore une fois je ne pouvais pas
correspondre au portrait robot
vous allez dire que c'est un truc de
journaliste mais je les aime bien quand
même donc je vais vous montrer il a été
noté votre message très chaleureux de
remerciements à jean castex d'ailleurs
le montre un téléspectateur vous avez
tweeté une photo de vous deux avec ce
message en merci amical chaleureux pour
ces deux années d'engagement mais
personne n'a vu le message de
félicitation pour isabelle borne
supérieure à ce que je lui ai fait un
message de félicitations de vive voix
personnelle de lorsque nous nous sommes
rencontrés et a bien pas puisque vous
n'êtes pas une âme il ya un moucheron
qui nous tourner autour je ne sais pas
si je vais arriver le voulait des
musiques mandingues visio oui parce que
les gens voient un petit moucheron qui
se baladent puisque nous avons noté vous
n'êtes pas une femme ce qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de grandes figures
politiques dans ce gouvernement est ce
que pour vous c'est un gouvernement un
peu de techniciens
d'efficacité on peut on peut pas dire
que papy n'diaye soit un technicien on
peut pas dire que bruno le maire soit un
technicien si vous reprenez les
principaux postes non je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire ça je pense que c'est un
gouvernement qui est très marquée par
les étapes antérieures quand c'est que
les gens ont fait dans le gouvernement
déjà il ya ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
ministres qui étaient déjà dans les
gouvernements antérieurs ou dans le
conseil du président de la république
s'agisse mais les deux tiers des risques
de l'allier des tiers sont des élus ou
pas mais franciliens il n'y a pas de
breton regrette certains il ya personne
du sudes et du sud ouest et du sud ouest
donc est ce que pour vous c'est sans
doute peut-être le principal défaut de
ce gouvernement bien comme vous avez jeu
je vois que vous avez une capacité à me
prêter dépenses et non je pense que le
plus les gouvernements sont équilibrés
et mieux c'est
vous l'avez ou
alors et tiens en parlant des criées
monsieur meyrueis qu'il est équilibré ce
gouvernement quand on prend l'ordre
protocolaire l'économie l'intérieur les
affaires étrangères mais aussi les armes
et les ministres viennent de droite est
ce que c'est un gouvernement de droite
c'est drôle vous commencer l'émission en
me parlant d'une polémique de la droite
contre un des ministres du gouvernement
et on peut ainsi faire le fer le tout
non c'est un gouvernement que le
président de la république a voulu
ouvert
rassembleur et il met en effet des gens
qui ont une expérience et un chemin à
droite et des gens qui ont une
expérience et un chemin à gauche comme
on vient de le voir le
et au fond il a choisi
je sais comment il réfléchit je
m'arrive d'en parler avec lui éclairer
nos
il a essayé de choisir
et solutions pour les problèmes qui se
posent avec des personnalités dont il
pensait qu'elle pouvait porter les
solutions
et et il a voulu symboliquement en effet
une femme à la tête mais justement je
poursuis la question jean baptiste des
ministres de droite sur le régalien et
l'économie et les mini socialement les
ministères socialement explosif confiés
à des ministres de gauche la santé
l'éducation nationale le travail il n'y
a pas de hasard la question c'est savez
vous mieux placé que moi pour le savoir
un bon ministre c'est quelqu'un qui
gagne ses arbitrages budgétaires est ce
que ça va faire des étincelles grosso
modo entre ce minimum à 2 go je ne
pouvais pas marcher je vais dire je vais
la corsa ne connais pas
je ne participe pas à ces stéréotypes
je ne crois pas que les gens issus de la
droite soit plus doués pour résoudre les
problèmes économiques ou de sécurité que
les gens qui viennent de la gauche ou du
centre croit pas du tout ça je pense que
ça dépend des parcours personnels mais
je ne ne colle pas une étiquette très
bien alors soyons concrets monsieur
bayrou a par exemple parlé de pap ndiaye
il ya quelques instants pap ndiaye il a
sans doute des idées je suis sûr que ça
va être un bon ministre mais au moment
d'aller passer par jetair les moyens
pour l'éducation nationale va bien
falloir aller les négocier à bercy mais
est ce que est ce que vous imaginez
qu'un ministre de l'éducation nationale
qui pèse son poids n'est pas en
situation de gagner ses arbitrages c'est
la question que les à négocier c'est la
question que je pense je il se trouve
que j'ai fait ça dans ma vie si vous
avez du poids vous gagnez vos arbitral
si vous avez du poids et si vous savez
identifier et nommer les problèmes qui
se posent pour les gens
alors vous gagnez comme vous dites vos
arbitrage il n'est pas possible de
conduire une politique l'éducation
nationale sans avoir en effet les moyens
qui s'imposent ça n'est pas possible et
je vais ajouter une chose s'il y avait
des difficultés sur ce point on est un
certain nombre à être là pour relayer
les nécessités pour pouvoir faire
entendre une voix très là pour le
soutenir oui pour soutenir les exigences
du pays dans ses affaires a bien eu mans
crucial françois méro il ya une surprise
pour certains en tout les cas qu'ils
provoquent pour certains ce même une
provocation eric dupond-moretti conserve
le ministère de la justice garde des
sceaux ce qui provoque l'ire du syndicat
de la magistrature qui s'indigne de
cette décision
puisqu'il a été mise en examen par la
cour de la justice de la république est
ce que pour vous à eric dupond-moretti
vu que lui il a gagné des arbitrages
justement il a obtenu des hausses de son
budget sera donc très important de
nombre considérable de magistrats
supplémentaires
on voit bien ce rapport de force avec la
magistrature est-ce que c'est pas un peu
de la provocation de le maintenir à ce
poste là c'est une décision politique on
va essayer je décide de changer du moins
tant monsieur bayrou que vous-même garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice vous
deviez quitter cette fonction après 35
jours la gare aux affaires que nous
avons évoqué en début d'émission fausse
affaire tout cas à mon avis et ça sera
je le prouverai nous le prouvons
je vais répondre à votre question et on
va répondre comme on disait les
philosophes du moyen-âge a contrario
imaginer qu eric dupond moretti était et
est remplacé dans cette fonction qu'est
ce que vous auriez dit je riais dit que
les magistrats les syndicats ont eu la
peau de garde des sceaux c'est ça
c'est indiscutable et bien le président
de la république n'a pas voulu qu'il
soit imaginer qu'on donne satisfaction à
un corps
contre le ministre chargé de peu de
porter une politique d'intérêt général
comme ça que je vois les choses et
je comprends on va vous avez été
consultés sur quasiment chaque
nomination de pasta
on ne peut pas avoir que des faiblesses
il devait partir avez vous été consultés
sur l'avenir des ministres candidats ils
sont quinze ministres candidats pour les
élections législatives je pose une
question simple est-ce que selon vous si
le père d'une autre partir et bien vous
demanderez ça au président de la
république je demande votre avis non ce
n'est pas la formation du gouvernement
c'est la responsabilité du président de
la république et de la première ministre
matin c'est leur responsabilité
il peut arriver qu'on maintienne
quelqu'un parce qu'il a mené un combat
extrêmement difficile extrêmement
symbolique et que
et que on décide que pour l'équilibré
l'intérêt général alors on ne peut pas
se contenter d'une défaite pour l'ex le
cip et puis il arrive que ces défaites
soit significative alors évidemment on
les change mais vous demanderez au
président de la république je vous
demande à vous autres choses c'est un
sujet qui vous tient à coeur toujours en
conséquence des législatives nouvelles
élections législatives sans
proportionnelle à la clé
c'est un thème qui vous est cher vous
étiez battu auprès d'emmanuel mâcon pour
essayer de l'obtenir il avait d'ailleurs
lui-même promis en 2017
l'opposition le souhaite mais ça n'est
toujours pas là non non il y avait deux
oppositions qui ne le souhaitait pas je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il s'en mordrait
les doigts et serait volontiers décidé à
changer ça c'était l air et le ps un des
deux
profitant du scrutin majoritaire et et
contre tous les autres étaient plus que
j'ai signé une lettre de au président de
la république chez eux que nous avons
porté ensemble que j'ai écrite et qui a
été signé par de marine le pen à jean
luc mélenchon en passant par les
écologistes le centre et des
personnalités de droite comme gérard
longuet et 2 et de gauche comme le
françois rebsamen
donc
c'est une question très importante
de cette question dépend l'equilibre
ultérieure de des institutions en france
c'est de ça que ça dépend est ce que les
les citoyens vont avoir la garantie que
ils seront représentés
à proportion de ce qu'ils peuvent mais
combien j'en avais pas dit toujours ce
sujet national je dis que oui parce
qu'il l'a promis lui même de manière
absolument explicite par ce grand débat
trans partisan qu'on va mener et dont je
ne doute pas que en tout cas sur ce
point via d'autres points plus compliqué
mais ils conduisent à la proposition
d'un changement ou d'un du choix d'une
loi électorale juste ans injuste
et pour moi c'est très important on va
parler dans quelques instants du pouvoir
d'achat l'une des questions fondamental
dans l'esprit des français qui a pesé
sur la campagne présidentielle en
l'occurrence et très honnêtement quand
on a du mal à finir les fins de mois a
payé son plein d'essence une réforme des
institutions
c'est la priorité des français vous ne
pensez vraiment
si un journaliste de premier plan pense
que l'expression démocratique et
secondaire
parce que j'ai dès lors nous sommes en
effet passés la priorité de celles et
ceux qui nous regardent mais bien ses
formes ancestrales là dessus ça n'est
pas la priorité pour les fins de mois
mais c'est la priorité quand ils veulent
un pays juste c'est la priorité quand
ils veulent que leur que leur voix soit
entendue vous n'avez pas vu ce qui s'est
passé au moment dé gilet jaune vous avez
suivi des ou
centaines de milliers millions de
personnes qui manifestent à leur manière
et une grande partie du reste du pays
qui donne on est solidaire de ça si vous
ne vous rendez pas compte de cette
chapelle sa fracture de ce gouffre qui
s'est créée entre les citoyens et les
pouvoirs alors vous passez à côté donc
si c'est une priorité après la loi sur
le pouvoir d'achat très vite on lance
une réforme il faut en tout cas que tout
de suite on bâtisse cette réforme
questions plus personnelles vous restez
au commissaire vous avez démissionné
avec la soirée parce que ça n'est pas à
temps ce n'est pas lié au gouvernement
mais il faut que j'en parle avec le
président a répliqué passèrent en tout
cas j'en avais envie g j'ai une j'ai
remporté si j'ose dire en tout cas
contribué à remporter une très grande
victoire c'est que la planification
qui hier étaient je me souviens d'une
mission y compris avec vous dis-je et
hier était discutée moquer provoquer des
ossements des pôles comme si on allait
revenir autant
soviétique ou au plan de la guerre le
gosplan la planification est maintenant
devenu une donnée essentielle pour tous
les courants problème dans l'équipe de
la première mini ce rôle y compris pour
le président de la république et la
première ministre qui du point de vue
écologique en et charges pesant avait
plutôt envie et donc cette cette
question je veux j'en parlerai avec le
président blanc ça veut vous voyez bien
que l'introduction de la planification
dans des portefeuilles gouvernementaux
et dans des secrétariats généraux si
j'ai bien compris gouvernement pas bah
ça nécessite une une redéfinition des
choses vous pourriez être au
gouvernement hostile du coup on ne
pourrait pas tout faire non je j'ai dit
que je ne voulais pas être ministre je
les vis à l'avant ce monsieur bayrou le
pouvoir d'achat laurent demany
l'allusion ce sera le premier projet de
loi qui sera présenté à l'assemblée la
première ministre dit se méfier des
fausses bonnes idées et ré explique ce
matin dans la presse quelles sont les
principales propositions les français
les connaissent notamment la
prolongation de vue du bouclier sur le
pouvoir d'achat etc red star c'est quoi
une fausse bonne idée cette expression
m'a elle a interpellé la complètement
raison et je vais vous dire ce que c'est
une fausse bonne idée c'est de prétendre
que c'est le pouvoir politique qui règle
la question du pouvoir d'achat
parce que des gens qui disent le smic à
1500 euros pourquoi pas 2000 pourquoi
pas 2500 la suisse à un smic à peu près
de ce niveau là pourquoi est ce que ce
n'est pas une décision politique
parce que ceux qui dirigent les
questions du pouvoir d'achat ce qui
tranche le pouvoir les questions du
pouvoir d'achat c'est la réalité de la
vie économique s'il ya des entreprises
est ce qu'elles gagnent de l'argent
est-ce qu'elle crée des emplois est ce
qu'elles veulent se développer est ce
que notre commerce extérieur est en
ligne avec tout ça est ce que les
équilibres sont trouvés est ce que les
investisseurs ont envie d'investir en
france pour créer des usines pour créer
des entreprises la question du pouvoir
d'achat c'est celle là est donc l'idée
que
vous êtes élu vous arrivez vous prenez
votre stylo et vous dites à partir de
maintenant moi je décrète que le smic
sera à 2000 euros et bien ça c'est une
fausse bonne idée c'est tout c'est pas
une fausse bonne idée c'est un mensonge
alors c'est un mensonge dont se
repaissent beaucoup de propositions
politiques
mais c'est une escroquerie pour les gens
quand vous faites des choses comme ça au
bout du compte on a fait ça à certaines
époques sans entraîner à l'époque y
avait le franc une dévaluation immédiate
c'est à dire que les gens ont perdu
derrière le rideau l'argent qu'ils
avaient apparemment gagné ce devant le
rythme alors justement demain à bruno le
maire reçoit les acteurs de la vie
économique et celle entreprise et la
grande distribution pour fixer un peu le
cadre de cette loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat la question du bouclier
énergétique est pour l'instant
s'appliquer à tout le monde on l'a bien
vu que ça coûterait chaque effet les
caisses sont vides et puis aussi la
question du shaq alimentaire vous
quelles seraient vos préconisations
françois méro jusqu'où doit-on aller qui
doit être concerné pour éviter peut-être
de repartir dans le quoi qu'il en coûte
moi je pense que on ne peut que cibler
les aides sur ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin ça n'est pas normal
que vous et moi nous bénéficions des
mêmes aides que ceux qui sont dans la
panade parce qu'ils ont besoin pour
aller travailler de prendre leur voiture
tous les jours et qu'ils habitent à 35
km de leur lieu de travail c'est pas
normal
c'est injuste d'ailleurs quand jean-luc
mélenchon dit je vais baisser la tva
pour tout le monde la vérité qui baisse
la tva deux fois plus pour les plus
riches que pour les plus pauvres
parce que les plus riches consomment en
plus c'est eux qui vont avoir le
bénéfice est donc c'est il ya quelque
chose d'une escroquerie dans tout ça il
ya quelque chose d'un mensonge
d'un mensonge je fais pour piquer des
voix et donc 7,7 cette approche est une
approche que
oui je la teste qui à de fausses bonnes
idées tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
nous étions au devant d'une des plus
grandes crises que nous n'avons jamais
connu notamment avec la guerre en
ukraine les affaires étrangères et les
armées ont changé de mains nouveaux
ministres sont arrivés une dame colonel
sur le corps nu
est-ce que selon vous il aurait été
mieux d'avoir une forme de continuité
comme c'était le cas l'économie à
l'intérieur justement on regarde la
crise que nous traversons mais le le
ministre des affaires étrangères et le
ministre de la défense en réalité ce
sont les mêmes il n'y a que 1 ministre
principal affaires étrangères et qu'un
ministre principal de la défense et le
président de la république c'est ça
l'essentiel de sa tâche l'essentiel de
son travail et donc est donc le
les changements de portefeuilles
ministériels
l'une et l'autre était en place depuis
cinq ans il a le président a dû souhaité
une respiration est une question qui
pour le coup a des conséquences sur la
vie concrète des gens est ce que vous
êtes favorable à un embargo sur le gaz
le pétrole russe pour renforcer les
sanctions contre la la russie au risque
que ça pèse évidemment sur la vie
quotidienne des français sur leur
pouvoir d'achat la question se pose pas
en france elle se pose partout en europe
à ce que vous à titre personnel
favorable à des sanctions progressives
et décider en europe air dans le terreau
veut dire quoi de regret pardon montée
progressive des sanctions
internationales
oui mais je pense qu'il ya des étapes
ultérieures prévues je pense que le chef
de l'état russe dans la dans la dérive
absolument folle à la calice et dans
laquelle il est engagé
se rend compte que la montée de la
pression sur lui lui pose des problèmes
et je suis absolument certain que dans
la société russe il ya de plus en plus
de gens qui se rendent compte de quoi il
s'agit qu'ils se rendent compte de
d'abord du caractère
espérant de cette guerre contre des
voisins du coût d'une acquisition par
des frênes ce qu'il faut pas aller plus
vite plus loin plus fort sur ces
sanctions pour que la guerre cesse
d'abord il y à une sanction qui est la
plus importante c'est
les très grandes difficultés militaire
pour ne pas dire l'échec militaire que
la russie rencontre sur un certain
nombre de théâtres de ces opérations ça
c'est pour pour la russie c'est
sidérant qu'une armée qui est considéré
unanimement comme la deuxième du monde
soit à ce point
tenus en échec est repoussé c'est un
changement stratégique vous êtes tous
familiers des grandes réflexions
stratégiques que de gaulle a initié
juste avant la guerre de 40 en dix ans
que l'arm mécanique les blindés
l'aviation c'était ça qui régler la
question des théâtres d'opération et des
champs de bataille ce que les les russes
sont en train de découvrir en ukraine
c'est que ce n'est plus vrai ça sera
dans les livres d'histoire ce
basculement la main sur une race trois
minutes je voudrais quand même que nous
posions une ou deux questions et a
terminé sur un sujet un peu plus léger
surcoût fait d'actualité qui elle bat p
bah oui
alors pour le coup c'est une information
qui dépasse le simple cadre sportif
manifestement et à bien des biens des
égards est-ce que déjà pour vous c'est
une bonne nouvelle car est joué pourquoi
parce que c'est une personnalité
incroyablement attachante
j'allais presque dire c'est une
personnalité incroyablement française
désormais ya il ya quelque chose de ya
quelque chose de 2,2 ce que nous
espérons de la société française dans
l'itinéraire le parcours de ce garçon
dans l'assurance qu'il a prise dans le
dans la volonté qu'ils expriment de
force tranquille
et si ça pouvait s'accompagner du retour
de zidane moi je serais très content je
vais pour qui vous votez mais quand même
on voit qu'il est bon on connaît pas les
chiffres mais les chiffres désastreux ne
me quand même circulent sur les
conditions de l'est fait de son maintien
au psg est-ce que c'est pas quand même
un peu choquant dans ce dans ce contexte
de crise économique que la france n'a
pas connu depuis très très longues
années si j'en crois les chemises c'est
choquant mais les sportifs les grands
sportifs mais les grands chanteurs mais
les grands artistes ont en effet quand
on leur fait un chèque il ya beaucoup de
zéros sur le chèque
beaucoup
est-ce que c'est déstabilisant oui c'est
choquant oui c'est on pourrait imaginer
autrement oui mais
étant à la tête d'une ville à pau qui a
un grand club de rugby un grand club de
basket un grand club de football et même
un club de handball et d'autres et
d'autres spécialités on a été la ville
européenne du sport l'an dernier
je sais que c'est comme ça le l'idée qu'
on puisse échapper au monde
c'est une idée qui est vouée à l'échec
un dernier mot se trouve en vous baigner
dans un océan qui est un océan où ce
type d'intérêt est en effet très présent
et il faut essayer de le faire en ayant
une vision morale des chaudes un mot
français dans le regard de me bat p
moi je trouve quelque chose de positif
d'un mot françois bayrou la presse
espagnole dit depuis plusieurs jours que
dans cette discussion dans cette
décision de kylie ann mba paix serait
intervenu le président de la république
a noué des liens tout le monde le sait
avec qui il aime bape et depuis la
victoire en coupe du monde en russie en
2018 est ce qu'un président doit faire
ça à décrocher son téléphone et
d'iraqiya mba pc important pour ton pays
que tu restes dans ce pays au paris
saint germain et donc en france c'est
bon pour l'attractivité de la france
c'est bon pour nos relations avec le
qatar par exemple donc 2 j'écarte la
dernière partie de la phrase parce que
je n'en sais rien pas l'équipe bref mais
quand vous commencez la question en
disant est ce qu'un président doit dire
c'est bon pour mon pays et donc je
décroche mon téléphone la réponse est
oui
rien de ce qui est national ne doit être
étranger à un président de la république
digne de ce nom ça ne veut pas dire
compromission ça ne veut pas dire sortir
de son rôle
mais ça veut dire en tout cas qu'il sait
comment bat le coeur d'un pays merci
beaucoup monsieur bayrou merci d'avoir
été notre invité aujourd'hui dix jeux
lors on a très vite bonjour thomas
joubert bonjour fanny bec scheider c'est
à vous les amis je donne rendez vous à
tout le monde moi à 18 heures